Le 16 juillet 1945, dans le désert
du Nouveau-Mexique,
les Américains faisaient exploser
une bombe atomique
pour la première fois de l’histoire.
Le nom de code de l’opération était
« Trinity »,
et on était quelques semaines avant
Hiroshima et Nagasaki.
Tout ça était évidemment réalisé dans le
plus grand secret,
et il y a même eu un communiqué de presse
mensonger pour dire à la population locale:
pas d’inquiétude, c’est juste un bâtiment
de munitions qui a explosé,
mais on va quand même vous évacuer un moment.
Mais deux ans plus tard, en 1947,
les Américains ont déclassifié
et rendu publique une série de photographies
de l’explosion Trinity.
Des images qui ont fait le tour du monde
et ont été publiées dans plusieurs
magazines grand public.
C’était évidemment une opération
de communication
destinée à montrer les muscles
au début de la guerre froide.
Il faut se rappeler qu’en 1947,
les Soviétiques n’avaient pas encore
mis au point leur propre bombe,
ça n’arrivera qu’en août 1949.
Les images publiées par les Américains
étaient très spectaculaires,
mais évidemment la puissance exacte
de la bombe n’avait pas été révélée.
Secret défense!
Le souci c’est que Geoffrey Taylor,
un physicien britannique
spécialisé en mécanique des fluides
a pu utiliser les photographies
de Trinity
pour recalculer la puissance de la bombe,
et publier le résultat dans un journal
scientifique.
Et on va voir comment, nous aussi,
on peut le faire.
Car aujourd’hui on va parler
de l’arme secrète des physiciens,
ou du moins, leur couteau suisse.
Une technique de calcul qui permet,
sans trop d’efforts,
de se tirer de tout un tas de situations.
Cette technique, elle devrait
particulièrement intéresser
les lycéen-ne-s qui font de la physique,
puisqu’à part les explosions nucléaires,
elle permet, en quelque sorte,
de trouver la réponse aux exercices
de physique avant même de les faire vraiment.
Aujourd’hui, on va parler de
l’analyse dimensionnelle.
[jingle]
Commençons par une idée simple.
Quand on doit faire un exercice
de physique,
la réponse attendue c’est en
général une formule littérale,
c’est-à-dire une formule qui fait apparaitre
avec des lettres et des symboles
les différentes quantités qu’on retrouve
dans le problème.
Prenons un exemple concret:
Imaginons un pendule qui oscille,
c’est-à-dire une masse M
au bout d’un fil de longueur L
et placé dans le champ de gravité
qu’on a la surface de la terre, on va noter
g l’accélération de la pesanteur.
Supposons qu’on vous demande de calculer
la période d’oscillation du pendule,
c’est-à-dire le temps T qui s’écoule
entre deux battements.
La réponse attendue, c’est une formule
qui fait a priori intervenir g, L et M.
Après l’exercice peut vous demander une
application numérique, avec des vraies valeurs,
mais l’étape principale c’est en général
de trouver d’abord la formule littérale.
Un truc qu’on apprend au lycée,
c’est de bien faire attention
aux unités des quantités qu’on manipule.
Ça veut dire deux choses:
la première c’est qu’on ne peut pas
les mélanger n’importe comment,
on ne peut pas additionner une masse et une
longueur par exemple, ça n’a aucun sens.
On peut les multiplier, mais la quantité
qui en résulte,
son unité sera le produit des deux autres,
si on multiplie une masse et une longueur,
on aura quelque chose qui s’exprime
en kg.mètre par exemple.
Le second point essentiel avec les unités,
c’est qu’à la fin,
quand on donne la réponse à l’exercice,
eh ben les unités doivent coller
avec ce qu’on cherche.
Reprenons mon exemple du pendule.
Imaginons qu’après des calculs savants
vous tombiez sur la réponse suivante:
la période d’oscillation du pendule,
T est égale à M fois L fois g.
Voyons un peu les unités:
la masse M s’exprime en kilogrammes,
la longueur L en mètres,
et l’accélération de la gravité g
en m par seconde carré.
Si on multiplie les 3 unités à droite,
on trouve kg mètre carré par seconde carré.
Or ce qu’on cherche c’est une période,
donc un temps,
qui s’exprime par exemple en secondes.
Donc cette proposition de réponse,
M fois L fois g,
c’est forcément faux, les unités
ne collent pas.
Il faut recommencer et chercher autre chose.
Ce qu’on vient de faire, cette vérification
des unités,
c’est ce qu’on apprend à faire au
lycée il me semble.
Mais maintenant on va voir comment pousser
le truc plus loin, en retournant le problème.
Reprenons à nouveau mon pendule
dont on cherche la période.
On a vu que M fois L fois g, ça ne peut de
toute façon pas coller.
Mais qu’est-ce qui pourrait coller?
Sachant que comme ingrédients on a
M en kilogrammes,
L en mètres, et g en mètres
par seconde carré.
Essayons de trouver un truc qui marche.
Il nous faut des secondes à la fin,
or dans nos ingrédients de départ
il n’y a que g qui en ait.
Donc partons de là:
g est en mètres par seconde carré,
les secondes sont au dénominateur
dans l’unité.
Donc si je l’inverse, 1 sur g est donc
en secondes carré par mètre.
C’est mieux.
Il faut que je me débarrasse des
mètres qui sont au dénominateur,
je n’ai qu’à multiplier par L.
L’unité de L sur g ce sont
des secondes carré.
On y est presque, mais moi je veux
des secondes,
donc je prends la racine carrée de tout ça.
Racine de l sur g, c’est une quantité
dont l’unité est bien la seconde.
Super!
Donc ça "pourrait" être la bonne réponse,
en tout cas elle est compatible du point
de vue des unités.
Et c’est même mieux que ça!
Si ça vous chante, vous pouvez essayez
de trouver d’autres formules compatibles,
vous n’en trouverez pas!
Racine (L/g) c’est la seule façon
de combiner nos quantités de départ
pour avoir des secondes à la fin.
En particulier si vous essayez de faire
intervenir la masse M
vous verrez que ça ne peut pas coller,
on se retrouve toujours avec des kilogramme
dans l’unité
et on n’arrive pas à s’en débarrasser.
Donc la proposition qu’on a, racine (L/g)
c’est forcément la bonne réponse à l’exercice!
Cette façon de faire, c’est ça qu’on
appelle l’analyse dimensionnelle.
Et ça ressemble à un truc miraculeux: on
n’a utilisé aucun raisonnement physique,
on n’a pas parlé de force ou d’énergie
ou utilisé aucune formule du cours
ou quoi que ce soit,
on a juste regardé les unités et on a deviné
la solution à l’exercice.
Génial, non?
Mais attendez est-ce que c’est vraiment
correct ce qu’on a fait?
Est-ce que déjà c’est pas de la triche?
Alors non c’est pas de la triche, c’est
même plutôt une bonne idée.
Le physicien John Archibald Wheeler disait:
« il ne faut jamais se lancer dans un calcul
sans en connaitre d’abord le résultat ».
Donc l’analyse dimensionnelle, c’est bien,
mais c’est juste une étape préliminaire.
Le premier truc essentiel que vous avez
peut-être remarqué,
c’est que quand je dis que racine (l/g)
c’est la seule réponse possible,
en fait c’est pas vrai,
2 fois racine (l/g) ça marche aussi.
1/3 de racine (l/g) , pareil,
Ou encore pi divisé par e fois racine (l/g) .
En fait tant que vous multipliez
par n’importe quelle valeur numérique,
une constante sans unité, vous obtenez
toujours une réponse valide.
Donc la technique de l’analyse dimensionnelle,
elle ne donne pas LA bonne réponse,
elle donne la réponse à une constante
multiplicative près.
D’ailleurs dans le cas du pendule,
la vraie bonne réponse
c’est 2pi racine (l/g) .
Et le facteur 2pi on peut pas le déduire
par analyse dimensionnelle,
on est obligé de faire vraiment le calcul
et de résoudre normalement l’exercice.
Notre histoire de deviner la réponse
à l’avance avec les unités,
ça n’est pas suffisant, mais c’est
tout de même une bonne première étape,
avec quelques mises en garde tout de même.
Déjà pour que ça marche, ça demande
de bien maitriser les unités,
et notamment de savoir se ramener à un
groupe d’unités fondamentales.
Si par exemple une des données du problème
c’est une énergie exprimée en Joule,
il faut que vous sachiez que les joules,
c’est des kg.m^2 par seconde^2.
En général comme unités de base
on va utiliser des kilogrammes,
des mètres, des secondes,
et suivant les circonstances une unité
de charge, ou d’intensité électrique,
peut-être la température mais
ça dépend du contexte.
Donc utiliser correctement l’analyse
dimensionnelle,
ça demande quand même de bien comprendre
de quoi on parle.
C’est la première mise en garde.
Et puis, surtout, il y a des cas
où ça ne marche pas,
où ça ne permet pas de trouver la réponse
de façon non-ambigüe.
Revenons sur mon exercice fictif,
imaginez qu’en plus, dans l’énoncé,
on vous ait indiqué R le rayon de la sphère
qui se trouve au bout du pendule.
C’est aussi une longueur, qui s’exprime
par exemple en mètres.
Donc quand on fait l’analyse dimensionnelle,
comme solution dont les unités collent,
en plus de racine (L/g) on aurait pu faire
racine (R/g)
ou racine ((L+R) / g)
ou racine ((4*L - 7*R) / g) .
Et pire encore, finalement R/L, c’est un
rapport de longueurs,
donc c’est un truc, sans unité.
Donc on peut imaginer partir
du racine (L/g) qu’on avait avant,
et le multiplier par R/L, ou bien par
R/L au carré, ou au cube.
Ou même exp (R/L) ou arctan (R/L) .
Eh oui, à partir du moment où
avec les données du problème,
on arrive à fabriquer une quantité
sans unité, comme R/L,
on peut la mettre dans n’importe
quelle fonction du genre
exponentielle, sinus, logarithme, ce que
vous voulez et avoir un truc qui colle.
Donc le nombre de solutions possibles
devient infini.
Alors est-ce que dans ce genre de situation
on est cuit,
et on peut laisser tomber
l’analyse dimensionnelle?
Eh bien non, pas forcément,
mais pour le coup
on va être obligé de réfléchir,
et de faire vraiment de la physique.
Face à un phénomène ou une question, une
bonne partie du travail,
et aussi du plaisir, du physicien,
c’est de savoir quoi négliger.
Quels sont les phénomènes pertinents,
et quelle est leur importance relative.
Qu’est-ce qui va vraiment avoir une influence
significative sur le résultat?
Dans le cas qui nous concerne, l’exercice
nous donne
le rayon de la sphère qui est
au bout du pendule.
Ok, mais est-ce vraiment important
comme info?
Les forces principales ici ce sont la gravité,
pour qui c’est la masse qui compte,
et la tension du fil, qui n’est pas
dépendante du rayon de la sphère.
Donc le rayon de la sphère, c’est
un peu comme l’âge du capitaine,
en fait on s’en fiche pour répondre
à la question.
Donc on peut l’enlever de notre analyse
et, si on fait ça on a plus que g, M et L,
et on retombe sur nos pattes.
Alors oui si on voulait vraiment raffiner,
on pourrait se dire
que la taille de la boule compte si
les frottements jouent un rôle important.
Ou encore argumenter que le champ de gravité
en haut de la boule
n’est pas exactement le même qu’en bas.
Mais dans les deux cas on peut considérer
ça comme négligeable.
Au final, le fait que le rayon de la sphère
soit donné dans l’exercice,
c’était un peu un piège, vu que
ça ne joue pas sur la réponse.
Mais ça illustre bien qu’avant de faire
de l’analyse dimensionnelle
pour « deviner la réponse », il faut
quand même avoir une bonne compréhension
des phénomènes en jeu, et de leur importance,
et c’est ça aussi faire de la physique.
Bien, maintenant imaginons qu’on ait
fait tout ce travail.
On l’a dit, il nous reste quand même
un problème:
c’est le fait que l’analyse dimensionnelle
ne nous donne pas
l’éventuelle constante numérique
devant la formule.
Est-ce que c’est grave ça?
Si on veut une réponse numérique précise,
oui évidemment c’est grave,
mais si on veut juste un ordre de grandeur,
ça peut suffire.
Cette fameuse constante elle n'est rarement
ni très grosse ni très petite,
donc on va dire qu’à un facteur 10 près,
ça fonctionne quand même souvent pas mal.
Prenons un exemple avec un pendule
célèbre, le pendule de Foucault,
qui est accroché sous la voute du Panthéon
à Paris, à 67 mètres de haut.
Donc L = 67 mètres.
La gravité terrestre c’est 9.8 m/s2,
si on utilise notre formule de l’analyse
dimensionnelle, racine (L/g)
on trouve 2.6 secondes pour la période
d’oscillation.
On l’a dit, comme on n’a pas la constante
numérique,
le résultat est faux d’un facteur 2 pi:
la réalité c’est un peu plus de 16 secondes.
Mais ça donne l’ordre de grandeur,
ça permet de savoir
que le résultat va se compter en secondes,
pas en jours ou en microsecondes.
Alors OK pour un pendule ça parait
naturel, intuitif,
je pense que vous ne vous attendiez
pas à ce que le pendule de Foucault
oscille 1 millions de fois par seconde.
Mais faisons l’exercice avec un truc pour
lequel on a pas trop d’intuition.
Par exemple, si je vous demande quelle est
la pression qui règne au centre de la Terre?
Allons-y, cette pression est due à la gravité
de la matière qui compose la Terre.
Donc on va se dire que la constante
de Newton « grand G » doit apparaitre.
Intuitivement ça va dépendre bien sûr
du rayon de la Terre R,
et aussi de la masse volumique de la matière
qui la compose, on va la noter rho.
On va regarder les unités, et on va essayer
de les combiner pour faire une pression.
Les Pascal, l’unité de pression, ce sont
des kilogrammes par mètre par seconde carré.
Eh bien avec ce qu’on n’a, il n’y a qu’une
façon de le faire,
c’est G rho carré r carré.
Si on branche les valeurs numériques
et qu’on prend 5500 kg/m3
pour la masse volumique moyenne
de la Terre,
on trouve environ 80 GigaPascal,
donc 800 000 fois la pression atmosphérique,
pour la pression au centre de la Terre.
Alors en fait cette valeur est sous-estimée
d’un facteur 4 ou 5,
la vraie réponse c’est dans les 350 GPa.
C’est dû à deux choses:
la constante numérique,
qu’on a pas quand on fait l’analyse
dimensionnelle,
et le fait qu’on a implicitement supposé
que la densité était uniforme,
ce qui n’est pas le cas.
Mais bon si, comme moi, vous n’aviez aucune
idée de l’ordre de grandeur
de la pression au centre de la Terre,
ça permet de fixer les idées.
Perso avant de faire ce calcul,
je ne savais pas si c’était
1000 fois ou 1 milliard de fois
la pression atmosphérique.
Et grâce à l’analyse dimensionnelle,
j’ai trouvé rapidement
que c’était plutôt de l’ordre
d’un million d’atmosphères.
Et quasiment sans faire de calcul.
Une autre situation dans laquelle ça n’est
pas grave de ne pas connaitre
la constante numérique, c’est quand on fait
des raisonnements d’échelle.
Je vous ai dit que le pendule de Foucault
avait une longueur de 67 mètres.
Si vous fabriquez vite fait un pendule
d’un mètre, vous pouvez essayer,
sa période d’oscillation va être
de l’ordre de deux secondes environ.
Maintenant le pendule de Foucault, son fil
est 67 fois plus long.
Puisque dans notre formule la période
d’oscillation est proportionnelle
à la racine de la longueur, celle du pendule
de Foucault va être
environ racine de 67 fois plus élevée
que celle du pendule d’un mètre.
Racine de 67 c’est environ 8,
donc 8 fois deux secondes,
ça fait 16 secondes pour le pendule
de Foucault.
Donc vous voyez que même sans connaitre
la constante numérique,
dans le cas du pendule je vous rappelle que
c’était 2pi,
on arrive par un raisonnement d’échelle
à anticiper
comment le résultat va varier
quand on change un des paramètres,
ici quand on passe d’un pendule d’un
mètre à un pendule de 67 mètres.
Bien en guise de dessert, je voudrais
maintenant vous montrer
deux applications fameuses de l’analyse
dimensionnelle,
et on va parler bombe atomique
et théorème de Pythagore.
[jingle]
Revenons donc à l’explosion
de la première bombe atomique
dont je vous ai parlé au début de la
vidéo, le test Trinity en juillet 1945.
Je vous ai dit que tout avait été
tenu secret,
jusqu’à ce qu’en 1947 les Américains
publient des photographies du test,
histoire de montrer un peu leurs muscles.
Ces fameuses images montrent comme une sorte
de boule de feu,
qui permet de visualiser la propagation
de l’onde de choc due à l’explosion.
Dans les premiers instants, il s’agit
en gros d’une demi-sphère,
et ça n’est que plus tard, sous l’effet de
la montée de l’air chaud,
qu’elle prend la forme du fameux
champignon atomique.
Or les photos publiées en 1947 comportaient
aussi une indication d’échelle,
donc on pouvait mesurer la taille
de l’onde de choc.
Et c’est ça qui a permis au physicien
Geoffrey Taylor
d’estimer la puissance de la bombe,
alors que ce chiffre avait été gardé secret
par l’armée américaine.
Geoffrey Taylor avait estimé
que l’évolution du rayon R
de l’onde de choc ne devait dépendre
que de l’énergie de la bombe E,
e la densité de l’air rho,
et bien sûr du temps écoulé t.
Essayons de raisonner avec de
l’analyse dimensionnelle.
Si ce que Taylor dit est vrai, il doit donc
exister une relation entre ces 4 quantités.
En regardant les unités, on peut trouver
qu’il n’y a qu’une seule manière de les relier,
c’est d’écrire que E est égale à rho
fois R puissance 5 divisé par t au carré.
Vous pouvez essayer, il n’y a que ça
qui fonctionne, c’est la seule possibilité.
Si maintenant on prend une seule
photo de l’explosion, disons celle-ci,
on peut en principe faire le calcul
de l’énergie de la bombe.
Avec l’échelle de longueur,
on peut estimer
le rayon de la demi-sphère
à environ 130 mètres.
Le temps on l’a, c’est 0.025 secondes,
et pour la masse volumique de l’air
on va prendre 1.3 kg/m3.
On met tout ça dans la formule, on
trouve 7.7 10^13 Joules.
Pour comparer, un kg de TNT
c’est 4.18 mégajoules,
donc ça nous fait une énergie estimée
d’environ 19 000 kilos de TNT.
On sait aujourd’hui que la bombe a en
réalité dégagé
une énergie comprise entre 21
et 25 000 kilos de TNT.
Donc notre estimation par analyse
dimensionnelle
à partir d’une seule photo, elle est
carrément pas mal!
Surtout pour un truc supposément classé
"secret défense".
Ils sont vraiment stupides ces militaires
américains.
Alors non, il faut quand même préciser
plusieurs choses,
parce que ça semble marcher tellement bien
que l’histoire est parfois un peu romancée.
Premièrement, vous voyez dans la formule que
l’énergie dépend du rayon à la puissance 5.
Donc il faut vraiment avoir une bonne
estimation du rayon.
En pratique, Geoffrey Taylor a utilisé
toute une série d’images,
et il a fait une régression pour améliorer
la précision.
Ensuite je vous l’ai dit plusieurs fois,
l’analyse dimensionnelle
ne donne pas la constante numérique
devant la formule.
Le fait que l’on soit tombé sur quasiment
la bonne valeur,
ça veut dire qu’ici, cette constante
est très proche de 1,
ce qui n’avait absolument rien de garanti
a priori, c’est même un peu miraculeux.
Et puis surtout l’analyse dimensionnelle
ne fonctionne
que si on a bien pris les bonnes
variables au départ.
Je vous ai balancé comme ça que l’évolution
du rayon de l’onde de choc
ne dépendait que de l’énergie libérée par
la bombe et de la masse volumique de l’air.
Mais pour en arriver à cette conclusion,
Geoffrey Taylor a dû sévèrement
étudier la question.
D’ailleurs il l’avait fait avant
que les images ne soient publiées,
et une fois les photographies disponibles,
il a vérifié si ça marchait,
et c’était d’ailleurs, semble-t-il,
une surprise pour lui
que ça fonctionne si bien, il ne
s'y attendait pas forcément
Donc ça n’était pas si simple que de
faire deux lignes de calcul d’unités.
D’ailleurs pour la petite histoire, en 1946,
un an avant la publication des images,
un physicien soviétique Leonid Sedov, avait
lui aussi publié, dans un journal
scientifique en russe, une analyse rigoureuse,
similaire à celle de Taylor.
Donc aucun doute que dès la publication
des images,
les Russes ont pu eux aussi, estimer
la puissance de la bombe.
Bien, après vous avoir j’espère convaincu
de la puissance
de l’analyse dimensionnelle en physique,
on va même pousser le bouchon
encore plus loin,
et s’en servir pour faire des maths.
On va démontrer le théorème de Pythagore.
Vous savez peut-être qu’il existe
un grand nombre de démonstration
du théorème de Pythagore, plus de 350
d’après ce livre.
Je vais vous montrer celle qui est ma préférée,
et qui utilise l’analyse dimensionnelle.
Considérez un triangle rectangle.
Je vais noter x la longueur de son hypoténuse,
et thêta le plus petit de ses angles.
Le truc qu’il faut réaliser, c’est que
ces deux quantités,
x et thêta, suffisent à complètement décrire
le triangle rectangle.
Si je vous donne juste deux valeurs,
disons x=10 cm et theta=37°,
il n’y a aucune ambiguïté, vous pouvez
tous tracer le triangle correspondant
et tout le monde aura exactement
le même que moi.
Un triangle rectangle est complètement
spécifié une fois qu’on a ces deux nombres.
Donc ça veut dire que l’aire du triangle
rectangle aussi,
elle ne dépend que de ces deux nombres.
Il existe une formule, une fonction,
qu’on va noter A de (x, thêta)
qui donne l’aire d’un triangle rectangle
en fonction de son hypoténuse x
et de son angle thêta.
Cette formule, si je voulais me taper
de la trigonométrie,
je pourrais certainement la calculer, mais
je vais pas le faire, j’en ai pas besoin.
On va juste se demander à quoi
elle peut ressembler.
La seule longueur qui intervient c’est x,
en mètres si voulez,
et à la fin la réponse doit être l’aire
d’une surface, donc en mètre carrés.
Si on fait l’analyse dimensionnelle,
on réalise que cette formule,
elle ne peut être que x^2 multiplié
par un truc
qui ne dépend que de thêta,
qu'on va noter f (thêta) .
C’est le seul moyen d’avoir une surface
à partir d’une longueur x
et d’un angle thêta.
C’est le point crucial, n’hésitez pas
à mettre pause pour vous en convaincre.
À nouveau, cette formule existe, je pourrai
déterminer la fonction f
si je voulais faire de la trigonométrie,
mais j’en ai pas besoin.
Je vais pouvoir direct démontrer Pythagore.
Prenons donc un triangle rectangle générique,
dont on va appeler les côtés a, b et c,
et cet angle on va l’appeler alpha.
L’aire de ce triangle, j’applique
ma formule, c’est c^2 f (alpha) .
Maintenant je vais tracer la hauteur ici.
L’angle qui se trouve ici, c’est
aussi l’angle alpha.
Vous pouvez vous en convaincre en disant
que la somme des angles dans un triangle
fait 180°.
Maintenant je vais calculer l’aire de
ces deux triangles, le rouge et le bleu.
Pour le rouge, j’applique la formule, son
hypoténuse à lui c’est a,
donc son aire c’est a^2 f (alpha) .
Et le bleu son hypoténuse c’est b,
donc son aire c’est b^2 f (alpha) .
Maintenant je n’ai plus qu’à écrire
que l’aire du triangle de départ
c’est la somme des aires des deux
petits triangles,
je simplifie par f (alpha)
que je n’ai pas besoin de connaitre,
et hop: je tombe sur Pythagore
c^2 = a^2 + b^2
Le raisonnement qu’on a eu ici,
on peut le rapprocher
de celui qui m’a permis de passer du pendule
d’un mètre au pendule de Foucault.
Avec un raisonnement d’échelle on peut
relier des quantités,
et pas besoin de connaitre
la constante numérique,
ici c’est f (alpha) qui est la
constante numérique inconnue.
Et donc avec ce raisonnement,
on peut démontrer un théorème de maths
avec de la physique, c’est beau non?
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui,
j’espère que vous apprécierez comme
moi la puissance
des raisonnements à base d’analyse
dimensionnelle.
Pour les lycéens, ça peut vous servir
pour vérifier,
voire anticiper les résultats
de vos exercices.
En ayant bien conscience des limites
et des conditions, évidemment.
Abonnez vous si ça n’est pas déjà fait,
mettez des pouces, des cloches
tous ces machins.
Pour ceux qui veulent plus de compléments,
rendez-vous comme toujours
sur le blog "Science étonnante",
le lien est dans la description
et puis on se retrouve très vite pour
une nouvelle vidéo, à bientôt!
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -